Come on. Hey,
talk to me. Of course,
but only for a minute.
Then I have to get to work on this pigsty.
Coffee? No, no coffee.
Bobby. Bobby.
Last night I went online, alright?
And I found out
all of the women here that used to be big deals.
I mean, big deals. CEOs,
executives, judges.
Sarah Sunderson,
she used to run an airline with that perfect skin.
No, no, no. She didn't used to look like that.
None of the women did.
They copy? No,
no coffee. Bobby,
this is you.
That's right, Joanna.
This isn't me.
It's a whole new me.
I'm happy and I'm healthy.
Because I understand what's important in life. Yes,
your new book.
That's right.
That's what's important.
My new cookbook.
And my husband and my family are making a perfect home.
It's a lesson every gal needs to learn.
Especially you.
I'm your friend, Joanna.
I'm going to help you.
You need me.
You stay away from me.
You're driven.
Well, sometimes.
And you're selfish.
You wanna rule the world? No.
I can fix you.
I can change you.
What have they done to you